hey guys sean mccann is here with the
game spot news update xbox live gold
members what free games can you get
during the month of May well we're about
to find out from May first through May
fifteenth anyone with an active gold
membership will be able to download dust
and elysian tail originally an xbox live
arcade game when it was released in
August of 2012 it was reviewed
positively by gamespot with a score of
seven and it regularly has a price of
$15 as with all games with gold titles
the only requirement for downloading a
game is to have a current xbox live gold
subscription once the download is
initiated the game is permanently added
to your account the game can be
redownloaded at a later time regardless
of your status as an Xbox Live
subscriber on May sixteenth dust will be
replaced by saints row the third also on
xbox 360 which regularly prices at
twenty dollars the third entry in the
series is perhaps the most acclaimed in
the Saints Row series it received an 8.5
from GameSpot now you'll notice these
are both xbox 360 games because well yet
another month has gone by without any
Xbox one games with gold despite
recently promoted ahead of Xbox Phil
Spencer saying earlier this year that
free xbox one games should be coming
soon if you're watching this video on
April thirtieth this is your last chance
to download the current free game
deadlight for more on free games that
you're going to download and probably
just forget to play check out gamespot
com